okay i've this really should be you know
we have all these clips on youtube 10
million views 8 million views 6 million
views
this should really be one of our most
viewed clips ever on youtube i'm not
saying it will be but it should be
we were on the ground in texas austin
texas this weekend for the trump event
our correspondent luke beasley was there
luke this is the second time luke has
done stuff on the ground for us he's
doing an incredible job you can find his
youtube channel at davidpakman.com
luke that's l-u-k-e okay
um we're going to go through some of
these clips of luke talking to people
and i mean
just prepare yourselves i don't think
we've ever seen anything like this this
combination of ignorance delusion
paranoia conspiracy thinking let's just
jump right in playing for the audience
what that sign is all about
well
that sign is about
open border
yeah you know
every country protest the the
the countries the people
by the border every country have a
border why
buy them open so the sign says biden
just dropped the bomb on us the american
people what can we do now wait until
2024.
what about if we lose again so can we do
something yes we can the real question
is can you pay the price there are some
tips then you should be do i no ever
give a job to this illegal people and
not ever buy something from them okay
anyway by the way it's the it's so funny
because corporations keep hiring
undocumented immigrants the message
really shouldn't be to joe biden it
should be to the corporations and we've
had a justice system in the in the us
for a long time republican or democrat
alike that they don't really go after
the companies hiring the undocumented
immigrants anyway continue
but you're you're you understand that at
the border
thousands upon thousands of people are
getting detained every single day and
thousands of people are being deported
so we're enforcing the border just maybe
not as much as you would like
well
i don't think i don't think a thousand
people is a departure i think nobody's
deported right now so this is an
individual
who has been convinced that all
deportations have stopped under joe
biden obviously that's not true but he
believes it
yes thousands of people are being
deported
so
how do you argue with that nah there's
nobody being deported now well if you
believed that i could understand being
confused but of course deportations have
obviously continued under joe biden next
clip this is about the election being
stolen
and people's
uh feelings about it runs in 2024
um and he loses do you think it'll also
be stolen again
it could be possibly but there's no way
to
say that it will be or won't be
and how will you tell if it is or is it
like do you think he could just lose
fair and square beautiful yeah he could
very possibly but i mean
we feel this last election was rigged
and
that there are a lot of unknown voters
that have passed and how do you vote if
you're dead
so the dead voters conspiracy widely
debunked
you're saying people used the names of
dead voters yes to vote even though that
hasn't been
shown on any of the court cases or
anything
but research from who i'm not exactly
sure research he's not sure about shows
dead people voted and i'd have to ask
the person who told me this and he's not
with see that's a fast that's actually a
very interesting thing
i'd have to ask the person who told me
this about the research well you should
have asked that right away in other
words this guy accepted it now that luke
is saying well what's your what's your
evidence for dead people voting he goes
i'd have to ask the person who told me
well that's what you should do right
away
that's hopefully an instructive moment
here's another woman who feels that the
election was stolen
from donald trump
um and then 2020 you think it was stolen
yeah from trump for sure and what makes
you believe that
i just i believe it i i when i
registered here in austin the register
in austin texas man when
i was uh changing states and she was
laughing at me like a week and a half
before the election going haha this
election's already been decided i was in
the car i had a witness i'm a caregiver
i was driving
do you think she had a witness she just
meant since biden was so ahead in the
polls no he was not ahead without polls
and no no i mean like uh polling was
cynical and uh
no no no no no no because i bet money
was somebody that biden will win but it
wasn't because i had inside information
i mean just beautifully done there by
luke
i don't have insider information it's
just a feeling just a feeling
and and just with the comment i mean
just walk around walk around the
comments she heard while walking around
austin and her feeling proves to her
that there was a national conspiracy to
steal the election from uh trump and by
the way she she voted in texas where
trump won so why would they be talking
in texas where trump won i mean just
none of it makes sense
walk around yeah all right so as you can
tell this is extraordinarily disturbing
this may be the most interesting clip of
all luke speaks to a couple
now the guy is wearing an american flag
vest
a backwards american flag t-shirt and
then the woman with the guy is wearing a
save what does it say i guess it's a
save america dress you'll notice that
when they realize that the interview's
not going super well
she whispers to the guy that maybe they
should end this and she walks away this
is really good work on the ground check
this out i'm here with the best looking
people at this event what are you guys
hoping to see here at the uh
the speech
i'm looking for anything that has to do
with election fraud uh we came to hear
dinesh and the new movie 2000 mules how
to avoid this going forward imagine
being like i want to figure out how to
avoid fraud going forward i'm going to
go to an event and listen to dinesh
d'souza
my recommendation so your whole audience
is everybody needs to take off sometime
in november let's get to every ballot
location with video and start
videotaping this so it doesn't happen
again okay what about you and i'm from
philadelphia pennsylvania where
obviously they had 1100 mules um there
were no mules i mean listen i learned
there were zebras spotted at some
polling places
and an occasional donkey but there have
been no mules whatsoever
i just wanted to ask dinesh what is it
that we could do differently for the
next election can you imagine and
obviously i know it's really nice to be
around a lot of other patriots
so here's my question on that when i
hear people talk about this i want to
give it the time of day but then you
look at every official medium that you
would make you know prove that the
course all those things and it's not and
it's not like there's no even people
that trump appointed
so this is great the woman says the
courts are corrupt and luke points out a
lot of those courts are run by trump
appointed judges the woman has no answer
she just turns and looks at the guy
she literally she just gave she just
white flag and just looks at the guy
that's a good question so the thing is
we all know that it happens
so we i don't know that but what's that
i don't know that well i need evidence
to believe something like that
i know so listen it's there's
how about this social media only seems
to censor liberals because they never
talk how great biden is they only seem
to censor liberals i assume he means
conservatives like this guy it's just
nothing's making sense
81 million people have you have to see
anything pro biden how about you
i think biden's done good stuff there's
some probiotic stuff
american rescue plan getting out of
afghanistan managing the russia ukraine
war taxes at its 40-year high understand
taxes at a 40-year high biden hasn't
done tax reform that's super interesting
taxes are biden hasn't done stuff on
taxes
given giving baby formula to immigrants
coming over the border except the um but
on the baby formula i think you do
understand that that's like
point zero zero percent one percent of
baby formula
are you affected by the baby formula i'm
not but if they don't get it their
babies starve if americans here they can
find other ways to get it but they're
stuck detained what about the americans
that are affected
and we need to help them as well and
that's what we're trying i'm sure
they're trying to do any immigrant of
course not
they're all important like the fact that
our tax money goes to the ukraine where
it gets london back to these corrupt
politicians the tax money goes to the
ukraine where it gets laundered back
what and the media media journals that
are all liberal much like yourself you
keep on spinning this there's no
escaping he has done nothing right man
this is this is real much like yourself
kid
um he took to talk to a guy about the
death penalty
the guy said the women should be killed
um women should be killed uh if they
have an abortion
i mean listen he's for the death penalty
he believes abortions murder
you do the math um so big news roe v
wade
looks like it's gonna be overturned yeah
what was your reaction to that
so
no that's great it was horrible you know
horrible uh ruling in the first place uh
and all they've done is
muddy it up since then
so i think uh it's about time
okay and then in your ideal country what
would the rules slash laws be
on people getting abortions
everybody has the right to life
life starts at conception
uh
it's
science you know this is a human life
okay
we should protect life always
and the punishment if you got an
abortion
what do you think when you take a life
an innocent life
should be murder
it oh it should be murdered you didn't
say you should be murdered
like should the person get death penalty
yes he thinks people should get the
death penalty for having an abortion you
know what happens when
say for instance a guy kicks a woman in
the in the stomach
that's he gets a murder sentence in many
states
for the death of that child
kill the women who have abortions quite
a scene uh and then lastly
here is um there there's a this is an
interesting thing there's lots of folks
who are just obsessed with communism and
socialism but when you ask them any
follow-up questions they don't know what
the hell is going on here's a woman
who's very very angry about communism at
the trump event what are you hoping to
see
besides trump just like what do you want
to hear
oh
because i came from a communist country
and trump is the one who fights for
america
and
who's communist in our country who's
pushing communism
i came from a vietnam you know vietnam
is a communist country now and that's
why we love vietnam
we love vietnam by boat
and we
we don't like um you know communist i
understand not liking communism what's
the connection to liking trump because
trump is
he's a doer he
he loves
everyone and he wants to save america
from you know the liberals going to the
left
and it's not good
so it's
it's very bad so that's why
i'm here today crystal clear explanation
to support him because he's
you know he's fighting for it
so what's something that the left is
doing that's super far left because
they
they support china and we don't like
china you know
china is a communist country communist
people
and by the way increasingly china is not
really a communist country i mean
they're they're run by the party but
it's increasingly a capital it's china's
complicated but it certainly has no
connection to reality in terms of what
this woman is saying
they spread the you know
they they want to compare they want to
they want to
you know to make everybody
you know under them they want to make
everybody under them and the u.s
supports them so
they
because
you've never been to a communist country
i've been to china you've been to china
and what do you see in china what did
you see what do you see can you tell me
i'm curious i saw a lot of things but
i'm curious how this relates to the
democratic party
oh man
oh
because democrats i think both the
republican and democratic party are
pretty much not communist
no i don't think so no she doesn't agree
with that
wow uh so that's what's going on in
america
that's what's going and so when we
continue talking about how do we
deprogram how do we get through
that's the full scope of what we're up
against excellent work by luke beasley
you can find his youtube channel at
davidpakman.com
luke and let us know if you want to see
luke at more of these events
wow i'm going to need to take a break
just to recover from so many high level
ideas we'll be right back
there's been a ton of fear-mongering
lately by traditional corporate media
about the economic and financial
landscape and if you're looking for
financial news that's more calm and
collected without the hype without the
click bait check out our sponsor the
daily upside it's a free business and
investing newsletter it goes out to 350
000 people
including myself and it was founded by a
team of financial professionals with the
whole goal of just providing clarity in
context for the events that are
happening in the world of business
economics and finance every weekday they
deliver a morning brief followed by more
detailed stories about what's shaping
the economics and business world i read
the daily upside all the time
because it's informative it's witty and
it's not dumbed down i just read a great
article about the real impact of the
russian sanctions in russia
and if you're looking for a daily jump
start on the news that's affecting
economics and the markets the daily
upside is the perfect solution it's
totally free to sign up using the link
below